protesters in Berlin rallying against
sending battle tanks to Ukraine we were
the ones who fought two world wars which
we basically caused and they want to
drag us into this War I totally do not
understand
of course it is possible that Russia
will attack a NATO country and then
there would be a third world war and I'm
really against all this because we live
in fear
an ipsos Bowl published this week shows
support for sending heavy weapons like
lapper II tanks is down to 48 percent
compared to 55 a few months ago
three quarters of those pulled say they
don't want Germany to be militarily
involved
pacifism became deeply rooted in Germany
after World War II in the mid-1940s the
generations who grew up since then are
familiar with the slogan no more war for
them sending heavy weapons to an active
war zone is seen as a huge break with
the past and the wrong strategy
that is why the country's foreign
minister caused quite a shock last week
we are fighting a war against Russia and
not against each other
the statement is fatal and it is wrong
because of our history a German foreign
minister can never say such a thing our
constitution says Germany can never
again go to war
Franz alt wrote books about peace with
former Soviet leader Mikhail Gorbachev
and the Dalai Lama
he took part in large peace rallies in
the 1980s against nuclear arms
and like many Germans believe that his
country would never be involved in a
military conflict again but the war in
Ukraine caused a large dilemma for the
pacifist
I have always said No weapons but if a
neighbor like Ukraine is so aggressively
attacked like Putin has done and my
neighbor asks for help even with weapons
I can't close my ears but as a pacifist
I also say stop this war we need to
negotiate also with Putin I call it real
pacifismus or realistic pacifism
he's not the only one conflicted the war
has polarized opinion between those
calling for peace and those who want
more weapons for Ukraine it shows how
Germany struggles with both its dark
past and the dark reality at its
doorstep step step fasten Al Jazeera in
Berlin